[Music]
guys we have a problem i scoured the
internet for concrete textures large
scale concrete textures not the like
close-up concrete that you get you know
on every texture site i'm looking for
large like
dams or
large drainage ditches you know that
kind of stuff so what we're gonna do in
this video is head to three different
locations and capture a bunch of
different large-scale concrete textures
i'm going to show you guys all the
different things you need to watch out
for if you want to do this yourself
we're going to stitch them together on
site using wacom's new mobile
workstation and then we're going to head
back to the house and process everything
in photoshop and i just dropped my
concrete material pack it comes with 10
huge two massive scale seamless concrete
materials all pbr all handmade ready to
make your 3d scenes look super awesome
50 off for this week only link in the
description so we're right under the
middle of this giant beam right here i'm
choosing this one because there's not
any bunch of sticks or leaves on this
one it's just pure concrete i'm going to
throw this tripod down right in the
middle of this thing and take a series
of images across the whole top of this
we can't capture all this in one image
i'm gonna have to capture this in a
bunch of individual images that'll be
later stitched together in photoshop
so i'm just trying to make sure that
like i got like 40 to 70 percent overlap
within that range another thing i'm
doing is using the two second timer so
that my micro movements in my hands
don't add any motion blur all right so
we just shot the whole underside of this
bridge i'm going to bust out the wacom
mobile studio then we'll hit our next
two locations knowing that we're all set
wacom's mobile studio is my go-to for
any on-site work like this it's
basically a laptop and a tablet in one
it's great it's got a quadro p1000 gpu
and a bunch of shortcut buttons to make
things super easy and it's 4k resolution
makes for these high-res screen caps so
i'll go to file automate photo merge
and we'll select the jpegs we just shot
and hope for the best
sweet yeah this looks good i think
everything is stitched pretty nicely
everything's working and we'll clean
things up later on to the next spot
look at this wall
[Music]
how though this wall is it's got like
the pock marks it's got a bunch of
cracks in it it's got a bunch of swipes
and
scrapes and it's got spray paint on it
but then it's covered up by the city and
then re-spray painted we got
grunge marks leakage everything you
could ask for built into this wall and
we're gonna shoot shot by shot by shot
down the length of this thing make it as
long as you want so we're gonna go off
the tripod on this one again make sure
your guys's settings are all manualed
out you want manual
white balance you want manual shutter
speed you want manual iso don't change
your focal length keep it the same
throughout so i'm just counting my steps
[Music]
i take five steps and that's the 40 to
70 overlap between each shot i'm making
sure
to not get too close to the wall and not
to get too far away i'm keeping it
consistent so basically between these
two lines i'm just keeping that steady
rate the whole time you want to avoid
this kind of stuff these shadows any
texture you're going to shoot you want
to make sure it's like unlit there are
no shadows that are determining its
lighting condition
this is flat enough that we can change
it to however you want you know we can
make it overcast when you bring it into
your 3d program you can add a sunlight
you'll get some cool shadows and stuff
so this is perfect
[Music]
what are you gonna do about that keep
going all right
[Music]
so we have officially shot out all of
our concrete images we're gonna go back
to the place stitch them together in
photoshop and then we're going to
process them all and turn them into
usable textures for your 3d programs i'm
going to show you guys how to make
normal maps roughness and specular maps
in photoshop and clean it up make it
look nice let's do it
now we shot two different types of
panorama styles today traditional
panoramas and linear panoramas for a
traditional pano the series of images
are taken from one fixed point like the
underbridge series we did or the damn
wall series
for a linear pano the images are taken
as you move from one spot to the next
like in the case of our super long
concrete wall or concrete ceilings a
traditional pano is stitched pretty
simply but a linear pano is much more
involved and we'll go over both in this
video starting with the full process on
a traditional panorama stitch
let's drag our 16-bit raw damn images
into photoshop now since we shot raw
it's going to open up adobe camera raw
and that's exactly what we want because
we want to remove any sort of lens
distortion caused by our you know 24
millimeter lens on all of these images
before we stitch them together it's
gonna give you the best results
so we have all of our images down below
and hold shift select them all and under
the optics tab
i'm going to check the use profile
corrections box and you can see
when i turn this on and off
it's just applying a very small
correction to compensate for lens
distortion and we can select our camera
and the lens we used very specifically
from a massive list here to get the
right distortion correction the last
thing we'll do is make a batch exposure
adjustment
so i'm just gonna hover over the
histogram right in the middle and drag
this up
so that that mountain in this data is
right in the center of the histogram and
that'll give us a really nice exposure
to work with
so let's go ahead and open these up to
stitch these images together let's go to
file automate photo merge
and we'll add open files
yep this is fine these are all the files
that we need
and usually auto stitch with vignette
removal checked is the way to go
so let's just hit okay and that's a
pretty flawless stitch just to give you
an example this is with geometric
distortion checked and this is with it
unchecked so sometimes it can screw up
your stitch but sometimes it works out
so you just need to experiment with it
now this looks like a pretty solid
stitch right here so the next thing
we'll want to do is align this image so
all of our horizontal lines are truly
horizontal and all the vertical lines
are truly vertical without any sort of
bending or stretching effects so i'll
select all these images hit ctrl j to
make copy ctrl e to merge them into one
image and i'll just select the rest of
these hit ctrl g to group them just in
case we screw this up i'm going to hop
back into adobe camera raw control shift
a with that image selected
and there's a really cool effect under
the geometry tab
so i'll open that up and on the far
right you'll see this little uh hashtag
looking sign and that's going to allow
us to draw some reference lines that
photoshop can use to straighten out this
image we can figure that
you know this line here
along this edge is straight
and probably this one here
up the wall
right about there
so that's going to straighten things out
left and right but we need to do top and
bottom as well so
probably
this line looks pretty straight to me
and to be honest i don't know if this
bridge is curved or not but i'm just
going to go for it and say
that's a straight line
and that looks pretty square to me you
know we're not going to use this whole
image we're just going to use about the
center 60 percent of this thing so let's
hit okay and take a look at the
difference
you see that things are a little bit
more straight now so like i mentioned we
don't want to use this entire image so
we're going to have to crop it but i
would urge you to be very conservative
with the crop here because we can
content aware fill things out very
easily like this grass patch or these
bars and stuff
so i'm just gonna bring the top of this
crop down to the first usable bits of
concrete here this looks pretty good to
me all right almost there let's just
take care of all this stuff that we
don't need for our texture like this
grass and these bars and whatnot so i'll
use a few tools to get rid of the grass
the pipes and this concrete cylinder
it's going to be the patch tool content
aware fill the healing brush and the
clone stamp tool
so let's start with the patch tool set
to source
and let's just drag this to
another spot that
looks about right i'm just lining up
with these lines here
and it looks pretty natural to me that
feels good now to fill this gap we can
select this transparent space hit shift
backspace make sure contents is set to
content aware and hit ok and photoshop
is going to reference the entire image
to fill in these transparent areas
pretty well next let's try and get rid
of this
cylinder i'm just going to do a
selection around this keeping it pretty
tight and let's grab this bush too and
we'll do the same thing to get rid of
that piece that looks pretty good let's
grab the polygon lasso tool
make a
pretty tight selection
around this water pipe here again shift
backspace to content aware fill this
water pipe out of existence
and finally for this pipe here it's
actually giving me trouble with the
content aware fill tool so i'm going to
try the spot healing brush on this one
i'll click once at the bottom
hold shift and click once at the top and
that'll draw a straight line from point
a to point b
and completely get rid of that thing now
you can get rid of this paint patch as
well if you want
this feels really good to me this is a
really nice diffuse texture i'm digging
this a lot now before we make this
texture seamless i want to do a couple
color correction edits on this thing
let's make a levels adjustment i'll drag
the gamma up just a bit
and if you select the white box here
next to the levels adjustment and hit
control i for invert it's going to turn
off the effect but if we grab a large
soft brush at a low opacity
and we set it to
white we can actually paint on in this
little box it's tiny but i'm sure you
guys can see it and i just want to paint
in a little bit of the areas that are
feeling a little dark and on top of that
i feel like there's a little bit of
color balance issues between the
concrete here so i'm going to make a
photo filter effect
crank it up just a little bit
to warm things up we're going to do the
same thing ctrl i to invert that
adjustment and with that soft large
white brush i'm just going to paint in
the areas that i'm feeling like are a
little cool that need to be warmed up
just a bit and just like that this is
feeling a little bit better to me so
let's take all three of these layers hit
ctrl j to duplicate control e to merge
let's group these again just in case we
screw this up so now it's time to make
things seamless so when you tile this
material in your 3d program you don't
see the seams and this concrete wall
will appear endless
and the way to do that is essentially to
go to filter other
offset and type in half the value of
your resolution in our case it's 60 59
by 60 59
roughly 30 30 by 30 30 and this will
give you a tiled view of your image if
we can make this image look like it's
one image versus four quadrants then our
texture will truly be seamless
so i'm going to utilize the clone stamp
tool to make this seamless you can have
a large soft brush with a low opacity to
build up your texture over time i found
this is the best way to go when trying
to maintain as much detail as possible
content aware fill just kind of makes
things look a little bit muddy and you
can see that the sides are made seamless
pretty easily but the top and bottom is
a bit more difficult because there's
this real nice layer of leaky grunge up
at the top that you just don't have at
the bottom so what i'm doing is copying
a few of these cracks making them pretty
dark and putting them right in the
midline so it makes for a bit more of a
natural loop than just leaving it as it
is because mainly this texture will be
used to tile left to right as opposed to
up and down so this is looking like a
really nice diffuse texture that tiles
pretty well i'm just holding alt to test
things out to see how it works
generally this looks pretty nice
so we have our first complete texture
you can add some contrast with some
levels here and maybe take down the
saturation just a bit but this is a 6000
by 6000 image with plenty of resolution
to get into and zoom up in for 3d i
can't wait to use these on some large
renders very excited but before we get
into creating normal maps specular maps
roughness maps and all that good stuff i
want to talk to you guys about stitching
a linear panorama so i'm in adobe
lightroom i've imported my raw images
and there's three things that we need to
do to ensure that this can be stitched
together properly so here's what i'm
doing for every single image first i'm
gonna apply the lens corrections
i'm going to account for lens distortion
so i'll check this on and off you can
see it's taking care of vignetting and
it's taking care of our lens distortion
what you can do is go to develop
settings
we'll copy it and just make sure lens
correction is checked uncheck everything
else we'll copy and we could apply this
to
everything else in one swoop by shift
clicking everything right clicking and
pasting those settings that way we don't
do it one by one but for the rest of
these adjustments we need to do it one
by one so i'll just show you on one
image and then we'll hop over into
photoshop and stitch it together so
under the develop tab you can scroll
down and find the transform option
here's that same little hashtag we used
earlier let's click that and we're going
to manually align each one of these
images so one for the top
one for the bottom
and i want to find some vertical points
here that we can use so let's grab this
that's great and this one here
[Music]
that's perfect and we just make sure
that this is as clean as possible
i'm going to make an exposure adjustment
so if we hover over the histogram right
in the middle you can see exposure is
written on the bottom left i'm just
going to click and drag and get that
mountain right in the middle and finally
i'm going to crop this down so we'll
click the crop overlay here we'll make
sure the lock is unlocked so we can
change the aspect ratio get right up to
the ground there
right up to the top of this thing
and that is exactly what we need to do
for every single one of these images so
that we can stitch it together in
photoshop once again let's go to file
automate
photo merge
and let's browse for our images this
time
grab all of these
hit okay
we're going to check vignette removal as
well as geometric distortion correction
on this one auto is fine
and let's hit okay
and would you look at that it's perfect
minus this little piece on the end but
we can just manually stitch that on it
is very very close and i'm going to show
you guys how we can warp this image to
truly straighten it out and look how big
this image is 0.85
we go up to 100
and we have resolution for days the the
size of this thing is 181 000 pixels by
almost 9 000 pixels
so this is what we're gonna make our
master texture from so let me show you
how to account for this slight warping
on just a chunk of this image
with everything selected you know it's
just one layer breakdown with control e
i'm gonna hit ctrl t for transform and
if we right click we can select warp and
we can essentially move these bezier
points around until everything feels
just about right now if for whatever
reason you need to chop this up into a
bit more detail for the warp tool you
can come up to the top and you'll have
some of these warp options so you can
add
different little slices here so if you
want to just work on the left side of
this you can add a slice there and just
work on the left side and have it not
affect the rest of the image you know
what i mean and the same goes for
horizontal slices you can make a
horizontal slice and just work on the
top chunks generally you want to work as
non-intrusively as possible so the fewer
adjustments you can make on this thing
overall the better and now it's time to
make the rest of our texture maps that
will go along with these textures to
really make them shine and be completely
usable in 3d alright so let's make the
rest of these texture maps here the
difference between just this and the
combination of the other ones we're
going to create right now is huge so
your diffused texture or your color
texture it needs a specular or
reflection texture to tell your 3d
program which parts of the image are
reflective which aren't and everywhere
in between the roughness texture
determines how spread out your
reflections are over specific areas of
your image and the normal map tells
which parts of your texture are raised
or recessed creating the illusion of
depth so let's start with creating a
normal map here and i had no idea you
can create one in photoshop but shout
outs to windbush for filling us all in
you gotta go check out his channel so
the first thing i'll do is just
duplicate my diffuse texture i'm going
to right click it and convert it to a
smart object that way if we make any
mistakes or we want to change our normal
map we can and we simply just need to go
to filter 3d
and right here you have generate normal
map you can do a bump or height map as
well but i find that normal map is
probably the best in this situation
awesome so we have this dialog box that
pops up and we have a couple settings
that we can tweak to you know change the
results so from the top we have invert
height if we want to check that we can
see what it does basically what
photoshop is doing is anything that's
black is being pushed up anything that's
white is being pushed down or reverse if
you invert your normals and i think for
this image
this orientation works best for us
now you have your detail scale slider we
can crank that up if you really want to
go hot and heavy on it but i like right
in the middle and these sliders here
low medium and high basically the low
slider if i crank this up to 50 you can
see that it's going to take like a large
area of the image and give it more peaks
and valleys
over a larger distance but i like that
personally down to five percent the
medium detail is basically any medium
scale detail and the high detail are
your small finite details and that's
where we're getting the most out of this
thing so you can see if i take this to
five
it's really going to cut down and kind
of make it look a little blurry but i
like this up at around 80 to get that
real nice crispy detail out of this
entire image and that's a normal map
you'll notice that
specifically like this area here this
white chalk
all these little i don't know that's
bird poop or what but basically
the normal map is saying oh those are
recessed pretty heavily into the image
what you can do
is actually take your diffuse material
and
tweak it so that those white streaks go
away you can also take down these black
streaks too and say you know maybe
they're not pushed up as much or maybe
it's just you know scaling down the
intensity of your normal map but just
know that you can tweak your diffuse
texture to set it up for that normal map
so that it is as accurate as possible
next up we have our specular and
roughness materials so both of these are
similar in the sense that they are black
and white texture maps so the first
thing i'll do is make a little
adjustment here let's do black and white
and we can check this little box
right down here this is going to only
affect the image below it so it's just
going to affect the specular
bam i'll hit that and generally with
specular and roughness maps black is off
and white is on so for specular black
means it's not shiny at all
white means it's super shiny and this is
just going to determine how shiny
different parts of this image are so
with that i'm going to create a curves
adjustment and even things out just a
little bit i'm gonna drop the contrast
and i'll probably lower this just a bit
and it's gonna be about as simple as
that so we're saying that this
image here is
reflective but it's not super reflective
because it is concrete
and these black areas here are less
reflective now technically since these
are
like watery streaks we probably want to
invert this these bits are probably
going to be a bit more reflective than
just the dry old concrete so we can take
our specular
image hit ctrl i
and it'll invert that entire selection
and finally we have the roughness
channel so the roughness map once again
it's a black and white one so let's add
that black and white adjustment and
let's also check this box so it only
affects the image below it doesn't
affect all the other stuff let's create
a curves adjustment and again
if we know that white is completely
rough meaning
this is going to be more of like a matte
look like if you see the matte wraps on
certain cars
that's what this is doing it's spreading
out the reflection but if everything is
black that means it's going to be your
reflection is going to be super
mirror-like like your iphone screen
you're going to see those crisp
reflections
in the black screen essentially right
so knowing that we probably want a
little bit of roughness on our concrete
we want to spread out that reflection
just a bit
somewhere around here i think is
probably good so with that we have a
roughness texture
a specular texture they look very very
similar
a normal texture
and a diffuse texture and combining all
four of these together will get you a
really nice look in any 3d program that
you want okay so one last bonus tip and
this one is huge it allows you to
organize your custom materials inside of
qixel bridge qixel bridge is free and
they offer a bunch of textures materials
and all that good stuff i found out
about this from winbush once again he's
letting us know and he does a
full-on detailed version of what i'm
about to show you on his channel so
definitely go check that out the dude's
awesome so we'll just go to file import
assets and i'll navigate to
the folder that has the assets
needed and automatically it pulled it up
you know we can name it you can you know
select surface yep it's a surface
and it knows it's an ak resolution file
so we can choose all the different image
textures here so diffuse
all right we can choose our ak
and normal specular roughness right it
has all the stuff and it gives us this
preview file here so we can import this
and export out the 8k 4k or 2k
resolution versions of our material it's
amazing so imma definitely be plugging
all the rest of my custom textures and
surface imperfections into qixel bridge
and that just about wraps it up if you
want to get your hands on this endless
concrete material pack then this week is
the week to do it i'm running a 50
off deal for the next seven days only it
comes with 10 unique large to massive
scale seamless concrete materials
all ready to go and use in any 3d
program you want and amp up your 3d
experience the link is in the
description check it out but my goodness
what a tutorial we talked about the best
practices for shooting textures outside
and the difference between a traditional
panorama and a linear panorama we
brought those images into photoshop we
corrected the lens distortion we aligned
them we stitched them together and we
made them seamless then we created
normal maps specular maps and roughness
maps and then finally we learned how to
package it all together in quixote
bridge to get them out into your 3d
programs as fast as possible so get out
there and start making your own textures
i promise 3d is a lot more fun when you
start doing so
leave your tips and findings in the
comments below and if you haven't
already join my discord server it's full
of a bunch of like-minded artists just
like yourself looking to learn and grow
together and amp up their game in 3d and
tomorrow is the last day to get your
submission in for the dynamic machines
community render challenge
august 1st 11 59 pm pst is the deadline
so get your submission in the link to
submit is in the description as well so
don't miss out the incredible community
montage montages coming a little later
in august so be sure to subscribe to see
that and for a very big announcement
next weekend so i'll see you guys then
peace
[Music]
you